es ist zehn uhr wir beginnen mit dem
pressebriefing robert-koch-institut am
22 oktober 2020 wieder mit professor dr
lothar wieler präsident des robert
koch-instituts er wieder bitte ja guten
morgen meine damen und herren
zunächst einmal möchte ich mich bei
allen bedanken die sich in den
vergangenen monaten an die asl regeln
gehalten haben und dadurch viele
infektionen verhindert haben aber es
müssten sich noch mehr an diese regeln
halten und mitmachen denn inzwischen ist
die situation insgesamt sehr ernst
geworden
das infektionsgeschehen im vielerorts
rasant zu wir wissen nicht wie sich das
infektionsgeschehen weiterentwickelt
aber derzeit haben wir noch die chance
die weitere ausbreitung des virus zu
verlangsamen und jeder und jede kann
dazu beitragen wir sind nicht machtlos
sondern wir können etwas bewirken und
zwar indem wir alle
die aha + l regeln beherzigen und zwar
konsequent beherzigen
aber wir müssen damit rechnen dass sich
das virus in deutschland zumindest in
einigen regionen auch weiterhin stark
ausbreiten wird und dass sich das virus
sogar unkontrolliert ausbreiten kann
lassen sie uns einen blick auf die
entwicklung der letzten tage werfen
seit beginn der pandemie bis heute 22 10
22 00 uhr wurden dem robert koch
institut insgesamt 392 1049 kubik fälle
von den gesundheitsämtern übermittelt
darunter auch 9900 fünf todesfälle
wir schätzen dass etwa 306.000 menschen
die akute infektion inzwischen
überstanden haben die fallzahlen sind
seit anfang september
leider von woche zu woche gestiegen und
sie steigen auch immer schneller an
anfang oktober wurden täglich zwischen
1000 und 4000 fälle ans robert koch
institut übermittelt und inzwischen sind
es zwischen 4000 und 5000 fälle
heute haben wir mit 11.200 87 fällen die
höchste bisherige 2
in den letzten 7 tagen sind etwa dreimal
so viele fälle übermittelt worden wie
vor zwei wochen und bundesweit liegt die
sieben tage incidents pro 100.000
einwohner derzeit bei 56,2 fällen vor
zwei wochen meine damen und herren der
lag sie noch bei 20,2 und anfang juni
bei 3
wenn wir auf die grafik schauen ich
hoffe sie können die jetzt sehen dann
sehen sie hier aufbereitet drei grafiken
die ein wenig an einblick geben wie sich
das infektionsgeschehen in den letzten
monaten in deutschland entwickelt hat
auf der linken seite die
deutschlandkarte vom 22 august und auf
der rechten seite vom 22 oktober also
von heute man sieht sehr schön wie sich
die farben verändern links sehen sie
noch einen großen anteil von blauen und
weißen flächen das sind landkreise die
entweder gar keine fälle übermittelt
hatten oder wo die fallzahlen zwischen 0
bis 5 lagen
und sie sehen dann dass ich zum 22
september also vor vier wochen hin
bereits mehr gelbe flächen zeigen und
orangene flächen zeigen das heißt also
kreise wo 35 pro 100000 überschritten
wurden
im 22 september hatten insgesamt zwei
bereiche wo es rot war also über 50 und
heute am 22 oktober sehen sie die karte
ist deutlich dunkler geworden also das
geschehen steigert sich drastisch ist
ein sehr dynamisches geschehen und
zwischen haben wir viele landkreise die
über 50 sind und wir sehen nur noch ganz
ganz wenige landkreise die null bis fünf
fälle melden
es sind im moment allerdings immer noch
jüngere menschen betroffen
wir sehen weiterhin mehr leichte
erkrankungen als im frühjahr das ist der
grund ist das alter der betroffenen aber
der anteil der menschen über 60 steigt
auch wieder ausbrüche in alten und
pflegeheimen oder krankenhäusern neben
ebenfalls wieder zu und die
hospitalisierungen nehmen auch deshalb
zu das heißt also es werden wieder mehr
sowie patienten im krankenhaus behandelt
auch müssen immer mehr menschen
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
aktuell sind das 943 patienten auch
diese zahl hat sie in den letzten beiden
wochen verdoppelt und wir sehen leider
auch dass wieder mehr menschen hat coop
19 versterben als noch vor einigen
wochen
und wir müssen auch davon ausgehen dass
die schweren fälle zunehmen und auch
dass die zahl der toten wieder steigen
wird
ich möchte heute etwas detaillierter
darauf eingehen wo sich die menschen mit
saas kopf zwei anstecken
das virus verbreitet sich naturgemäß
überall dort wo menschen zusammenkommen
und zwar vor allen dingen dort wo sie
gerne und intensiv zusammen kommen es
gibt viele kurven 19 infizierte die
niemanden anstecken und dann gibt es
einige fälle die und zwar in bestimmten
situationen besonders viele anstecken
das sind dann die sogenannten super
spreading events zum beispiel bei großen
feiern im freundes und familienkreis bei
privaten geburtstagsfeiern
hochzeitsfeier oder ähnlichen feier ab
zwei fälle spricht man von einem cluster
oder einem ausbruch und die
gesundheitsämter versuchen diese cluster
der ausbrüche möglichst schnell und
vollständig nachzuvollziehen das ist
aber nicht immer möglich
man kann auch nicht immer in jedem fall
einen ausbruch zu ordnen das gelingt
eben nur bei einem teil der fälle
ich zeige ihnen jetzt eine grafik in der
aufgeschlüsselt wird wo ausbrüche
passieren
das sind daten die uns von den
gesundheitsämtern übermittelt werden
wenn wir die grafik jetzt einblenden
sie sehen eine grafik in der ausbrüche
abgebildet sind die größer als fünf
fälle beinhalten auf der linken seite
also die koordinate da sehen sie die
fallzahlen oben links steht die 6000 die
grafik zeigt die balken jeder balken
steht für eine woche fast also die
ergebnisse von einer woche zusammen und
sie sehen unten dann die wochen im
kalenderjahr also der höchste peak links
ist der im april und märz dieses jahres
dann diesen kleinen pick den sehen sie
im juno mit den vielen roten von sehr
starken roten fahne und rechts eben die
aktuelle
wochen und was sieht man hier auf der
grafe ganz rechts sehen die legende
diese grafik ist auch publiziert die
können das alles nochmal nachlesen im
epidemiologischen bulletin
und was will ich ihnen hier zeigen sie
sehen zum einen das am anfang der
pandemie also im märz und april sehr
viele blaue dunkelblau farben zu sehen
sind das heißt also das sind ausbrüche
in alten- und pflegeheim in
flüchtlingsheimen als auch im privaten
haushalt
und man sieht nun über die zeit nicht
nur dass die anzahl der ausbrüche
zunächst im sommer einfach weniger waren
wir waren da ja sehr erfolgreich in der
eindämmung und dass sie jetzt wieder
zunehmen seit september sondern sie
sehen vor allem auch dass die farben
sich ändern das heißt also die anzahl
der ausbrüche im privaten haushalt nimmt
deutlich zu
und das ist eine wichtige information
weiterhin sehen sie zum beispiel dass
die ausbrüche in verkehrsmitteln nach
den daten die wir von den
gesundheitsämtern übersendet bekommen
keine so große rolle spielen
im juni stecken sich also auch viele
menschen am arbeitsplatz an das sind
diese roten balken das waren vorwiegend
fleischverarbeitende betriebe und wir
sehen auch dass ausbrüche nach
übernachtungen beispielsweise in hotels
eher selten vorkommen ansteckung in
schulen beziehungsweise schul ausbrüche
werden natürlich auch an das robert koch
institut übermittelt sie sind zwar
bisher nicht sehr häufig und wesentlich
seltener als wir das zum beispiel von
influenza ausbrüchen kennen
aber klar ist die stärke die fallzahlen
in deutschland steigen desto häufiger
wenn auch schulen betroffen sein
ein großteil der menschen steckt sich
also im privaten umfeld an das ist das
wesen sich was ich ihnen mit dieser
grafik zeigen möchte und diese daten
finden sie ab sofort auch jeden dienstag
im situationsbericht auf unserer website
nun was heißt das für uns
welche schlüsse ziehen wir daraus und
das sind ja die schlüsse die wir ihnen
vermitteln möchten
es kommt im privaten umfeld zu viel
ansteckung weil wir dort sehr nahe
beieinander sind damit wir unserem
haushalt überhaupt anstecken können muss
das virus allerdings erstmal in den
haushalt gelangen
es muss ja irgendwie in den haushalt
reinkommen
und hier gibt es eben oft ein
zusammenhang mit privaten feiern mit
zusammenkünften von freunden und
familien die menschen stecken sich
ebendort an und tragen das virus weiter
in ihre familien oder wohngemeinschaften
und das geschieht obwohl aus der cosmo
studie die ja von der universität erfurt
federführend geleitet wird aber mit
beteiligung unter anderem des robert
koch instituts laut dieser studie wissen
zwei von drei menschen in deutschland
dass das ansteckungsrisiko bei privaten
treffen mit mehr als zehn personen
besonders hoch ist wenn wir uns aber und
das ist der sinn dieser regel an die aa
plus l regeln halten wenn wir also
umsichtig sind besonders auch in
geschlossenen räumen da stecken wir uns
weniger an und da stecken wir auch
unsere familienmitglieder und
mitbewohner weniger an und das ist die
gute nachricht meine damen und herren
wir können viel dazu selber beitragen
anstecken zu verhindern
und wenn wir uns angesteckt haben dann
können wir mit quarantänemaßnahmen die
ansteckungsgefahr für unsere familie und
freunde weiter verringern
meine bitte an alle daher bitte nehmen
sie die symptome ernst und nehmen sie
warnungen aus der krone waren ernst und
wenn sie sich an ihr gesundheitsamt wir
sind in den vergangenen monaten im
vergleich zu vielen anderen ländern auch
in nächster nachbarschaft sehr gut durch
die pandemie gekommen aber das haben wir
einerseits ihnen allen zu verdanken weil
sie sich an die a h und l regeln
gehalten haben und dadurch infektion
verhindert haben das haben wir aber auch
der tatsache zu verdanken dass wir in
deutschland eine gute strategie haben
die wir verfolgen von anbeginn wir haben
drei wesentliche elemente der pandemie
bekämpfung und diese drei werden
miteinander kombiniert sie laufen
parallel in der fachsprache ist dass das
containment die protection und die
mitigation das heißt also die eindämmung
der schutz und die milderung eindämmung
bedeutet neue fälle verhindern
das tun zunächst einmal wir alle durch
das einhalten der aha
dadurch dass wir auch die korona vanek
nutzen und dann vor allem natürlich die
gesundheitsämter
indem wir zum beispiel infizierte
isolieren kontakte nachverfolgen und
unter quarantäne stellen weil diese dann
andere nicht mehr infizieren können
schutz heißt besonders gefährdete
gruppen schützen zum beispiel gibt es in
vielen altenheimen sehr gute hygiene
konzept inzwischen um die bewohner vor
dem eintrag des virus zu schützen
bildung bedeutet dass man die
auswirkungen der pandemie abmildert ein
beispiel dafür ist dass man
behandlungskapazitäten ausweitet oder
das insgesamt nun bessere therapien zur
verfügung stehen und diese drei elemente
meine damen und herren eindämmung schutz
und milderung greifen ineinander und wir
müssen alles dafür tun dass alle drei
elemente weiter bestehen bleiben lassen
sie mich noch einmal das wichtigste
zusammenfassen saß kopf zwei verbreitet
sich überall dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen
unser ziel ist es die infektion auf ein
level zu bringen mit dem die
gesundheitsämter die krankenhäuser die
ärzte mit dem wir alle umgehen können
unser ziel ist so wenig neue infektionen
wie möglich nur so können wir schwere
verläufe und todesfälle verhindern nur
so kann unser alltag ohne allzu große
einschränkungen weiter gehen noch haben
wir die chance die ausbreitung des virus
zumindest zu verlangsamen
wir alle können dazu beitragen indem wir
die aha + l regeln beherzigen mindestens
ein meter fünfzig abstand halten
die hygieneregeln beachten also hände
waschen und in die armbeuge niesen wenn
man symptomatisch ist alltags masken
tragen und zwar bitte korrekt also über
mund und nase und dort wo wir in
geschlossenen räumen zusammenkommen
lüften und auch an dieser stelle nochmal
mein appell an die gesundheitsämter
bitte ermitteln sie weiterhin infizierte
und kontaktpersonen mit jedem fall den
sie erkennen und isolieren verhindern
sie weitere fälle sie die mitarbeiterin
mitarbeiter der gesundheitsämter sie
leisten großartige arbeit und für die
möchte ich mich an dieser stelle nochmal
ausdrücklich bedanken
machen sie weiter so wir alle sind von
dieser pandemie betroffen
und wir alle können sie auch nur
gemeinsam durchstehen und wir werden sie
gemeinsam durchstehen
vielen dank wir kommen zu den fragen
pro teilnehmer oder pro meldung ist eine
frage und eine verständnis frage als
nachfrage möglich wir gehen als erstes
zum deutschen ärzteblatt ja herzlich
dankbar wäre mein name ich heute noch
als den ort in der infektion nachfragen
sie hatten auch kürzlich publiziert dass
man nur bei einem viertel der orte sagen
kann wo das denn wo das passiert ist und
sie haben auch in ihrer grafik einen
großen bereich für weitere vielleicht
können sie da noch mal sagen ob das
einfach unklare angaben sind von
gesundheitsämtern oder die menschen sich
vielleicht nicht mehr erinnern können
und wie das mit dieser ein viertel dass
man die ein viertel der orte
herausfinden kann ja die gründe die sie
nennen das sind alles gründe warum diese
bereiche grau sind zum einen ist es so
sie sehen auf der grafik dass der
graubereich auch zunehmend größer wird
das heißt also je mehr fälle auftauchen
desto schwieriger wird es zum einen für
die gesundheitsämter das
nachzuvollziehen
aber es gibt immer fälle wo man nicht
die quelle nachvollziehen kann das liegt
zum einen natürlich auch daran dass sich
die menschen nicht erinnern es sind
nicht immer so einfache events an die
man sich erinnert wie zum beispiel eine
party im zuhause oder so sondern es ist
einfach so dass darunter alles fällt was
wir nicht in den gesundheitsämtern
erfassen
wir haben in den gesundheitsämtern wir
haben eine bestimmte software von
unserer seite wird die software zur
verfügung gestellt den gesundheitsämtern
aber die wird nicht von allen
gesundheitsämtern genutzt wird etwa 270
glaube ich nutzen sie zur zeit dort kann
man bestimmte felder anklicken
diese definitionen überarbeiten wir auch
kontinuierlich also die wird auch immer
fein teiliger das heißt auch über die
zeit wird es auch immer wieder andere
angaben geben die es vielleicht im märz
april noch gar nicht gab das anzugeben
also das heißt es wird hier immer eine
bestimmte graubereich sein und wir
müssen uns auch immer klar sein dass die
gesundheitsämter jahr insgesamt wenn sie
die ausbrüche anschauen es gibt ja auch
einfach viele einzelfälle
die werden ja gar nicht unter ausbrüchen
zusammengefasst aber es ist ja klar dass
die sich irgendwo angesteckt haben
müssen im rahmen von ausbrüchen das ist
oft nicht nachzuvollziehen das heißt
also die darstellung ist nur das was wir
von den gesundheitsämtern erhalten
manche begrifflichkeiten sind auch wenn
auch teilweise unterschiedlich genutzt
das ist also ein wichtiger ein blick
aber es bleibt ein großer teil von
graubereich und der wird geschlossen
dadurch dass wir dann in einzelnen
fällen aber nicht nur wir sondern
natürlich auch andere wissenschaftler
noch mal genauer ausbrüche
nachvollziehen hier wissenschaftlich
darüber publizieren um herauszufinden wo
sich die menschen getroffen haben aber
nochmal der entscheidende punkt und ich
glaube das ist wirklich sehr sehr
wichtig wir hatten gestern nochmal auch
sehr intensive diskussionen hier im haus
darüber
dort wo menschen gerne zusammen kommen
und wo sie sich eben auch kennenlernen
wollen
dort ist natürlich die interaktion viel
intensiver es gibt inzwischen sehr
schöne grafiken simulationen auch zb vom
reichen institut in japan
dort sehen sie da sitzen menschen an
einem tisch und wenn eine person spricht
dann sieht man wie also diese aerosole
und die tröpfchen aus dem mund dieser
person kommen und dann eben auf die
andere übertragen werden und wenn man
intensiv zusammen sitzt intensiv
diskutiert lacht und fröhlich ist dann
ist natürlich diese chance einfach viel
größer dass ein virus sich dann
ausbreitet wenn eine infizierte personen
darunter ist es ist deshalb plausibel
dass wir zum beispiel im bereich der
öffentlichen nahverkehrsmitteln bislang
ganz wenig signal haben wenn sie selber
mit oder s-bahn unterwegs sind oder in
der im zug sitzen in der regel
interagieren die menschen dort ja nicht
sondern sie befassen sich mit sich
selber es wird nicht viel gesprochen man
liest vielleicht ein text oder träumt in
die gegend oder hörten podcast was weiß
ich
und das heißt also da ist die
interaktion gar nicht so intensiv und
das ist dieser aspekt dass man intensiv
miteinander sich befasst und dann treten
natürlich dieser aro sole aus und dann
kann man sich anstecken und das ist der
entscheidende punkt dass man wirklich im
privaten bereich vorsichtig ist und
feiern wenn es irgendwie geht einfach
vermeidet und die anzahl der personen
die bei diesen feiern ländern sind so
gering wie möglich
zu halten will dann kann man auch
weniger anstecken vielen dank
wir gehen zu dpa falschen ski
mehr als 20 städte und kreise haben ja
schon gesagt dass sie den vollständigen
infektionsschutz jetzt schon nicht mehr
leisten können oder bald nicht mehr
leisten werden können stellt sie das
nicht bedenklich in bezug auf die
strategie
ja natürlich ist das ernst und
besorgniserregend das ist ja gar keine
frage
aber ich möchte noch mal folgendes sagen
wir haben diese drei pfeiler der
strategie und die habe ich ja auch im
frühjahr vorgestellt diese drei fälle
laufen ja parallel und je stärker wir
die eindämmung halten können das heißt
also je mehr die gesundheitsämter
leisten können desto besser
und schon nicht mehr leisten können was
sollen wir tun ja dass das genau das
wollte ich gerade erklären also sie
leisten so viel sie können wir haben in
den letzten monaten es gibt länder ich
will ihnen das ganz offen sagen es gibt
länder die vor einigen monaten die
kontakt nachverfolgung eingestellt haben
weil sie es überhaupt nicht mehr
geschafft haben die quintessenz daraus
ist auch wenn man es nicht mehr alles
schafft jeden kontakt dem er findet
jeden ausbruch die immer noch
nachvollziehen kann
dieser ausbruch vermindert weiter
anstecken das heißt also das ist nicht
befriedigend wenn man es nicht mehr
schafft aber jede und jeder anstrengung
die man unternimmt reduziert immer noch
das weitertragen von den infektionen das
heißt also der entscheidende punkt hier
ist dass wir nicht aufgeben dürfen
sondern weitermachen nach bestem wissen
und gewissen und wir haben wir unter
anderem containment scouts das wissen
sie das für rund 500 containern scouts
haben die dann unterstützen auch
bestimmte untersuchungsamt
gesundheitsämter und wir werden noch
mehr content scouts auch einstellen das
heißt also diese kapazität werden wir
noch erweitern aber ja es gibt
gesundheitsämter die com an ihre grenzen
aber trotzdem werden sie immer noch
gutes leisten können auch wenn sie nicht
mehr alle ausbrüche nachvollziehen
können das ist dann die fragen sie gerne
im vergleich zum frühjahr erwähnten sie
ja das schwere erkrankungsfälle und
todesfälle an geht es noch
anders aussieht würden sie diese
unterschiede bitte nochmal klarer
erläutern und wo liegt die todesfall
quote im moment ja also im frühjahr war
es so dass wir mit diesem virus relativ
rasch über also relativ schnell
überrascht wurden wir hatten zu dem
zeitpunkt zwar das wissen dass das virus
in unser land kommt aber insbesondere
die protektion also der schutz
derjenigen die besonders empfänglich
sind also alte hochaltrigen und menschen
mit vorerkrankungen
der war noch nicht so gut gegeben wie
das jetzt der fall ist inzwischen sind
die alten heimat auch die krankenhäuser
haben ihre hygiene konzepte verbessert
auch die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter sind wachsamer achtsamer
also insgesamt wird nicht mehr so
schnell dieses virus in diese in diese
institution hineingetragen
dadurch werden die alten und die
hochaltrigen und auch risikopatienten
besser geschützt jetzt haben wir ein
ganz anderes geschehen wir sehen jetzt
über den sommer und langsam ansteigen im
herbst dass sehr viele junge menschen
das virus tragen sehr viele junge
menschen infiziert werden und dadurch
einfach der anteil der alten geringer
ist der steigt aber auch jetzt das heißt
also wenn wir nicht wachsam bleiben wenn
wir nicht uns stärker und zwar alle an
dieser h und l regeln halten
dann werden immer mehr menschen
natürlich auch trotzdem in den
altenheimen infiziert weil das natürlich
und man kann ja diese altersgruppen
nicht komplett voneinander trennen das
heißt also wir sehen jetzt ein
langsameres einen driften von diesem
virus wieder in diese einzelnen
institution aber wir können sie eben
durch unser eigenes verhalten reduzieren
und insbesondere so dass die hospitäler
und die altenheime und pflegeheime eben
auch viel schneller sehen wenn das virus
reinkommt weil wir jetzt inzwischen auch
deutlich mehr testungen haben und ins
test strategie die dort auch angepasst
das heißt also wir können das virus
schneller dann aus solchen altenheim
raushalten
aber die zahlen werden zunehmen und
nochmal je mehr menschen gerade im
privaten umfeld sich anstecken tragen
die das natürlich auch in ihre familien
rein das ist der entscheidende
unterschied ein langsames diffundieren
in allen schichten der gesellschaft und
die institution und eine bessere
vorbereitung der institution trotzdem
auf das virus und wir müssen einfach
sagen dass für uns eben
verantwortungsbewusster erhalten müssen
ich hatte gestern auch eine interessante
diskussion wir hatten gestern zahlen uns
angeschaut
über schwere akute respiratorische
infektionen in krankenhäusern das sind
relativ wenige zahlen aber die sind
trotzdem ganz interessant dort war es
nämlich so dass etwa zehn prozent der
fälle in einer woche die wir so
betrachten von lungenentzündungen die im
krankenhaus behandelt sind sind menschen
zwischen 15 und 39 also in junge
menschen aber von denen das sind zwar
auf einem gesamtanteil derjenigen die
eine akute lunge zu dem krankenhaus
haben nur zehn prozent gewesen in der
letzten woche aber von den hatten 40
prozent eine kurve 19 infektion also
haben waren mit diesem virus erkrankt
und erkranken daran das heißt also die
jungen sind zurzeit diejenigen die am
meisten diesem virus ausgesetzt sind nur
noch vielleicht eine nachfrage zur
klarstellung mit den ländern die im
frühjahr die kontakt nachverfolgung
zeitweise eingestellt hatten waren die
staaten gemeint also richtig das waren
andere andere bundesländer also nicht
länder innerhalb von deutschland ja dann
gehen jetzt zur taz was schließen sie
denn jetzt aus den von ihm vorgestellten
ansteckung szenarien das würde ja
bedeuten ein beherbergungs verbot
scheint nicht besonders effektiv zu sein
auch irgendwelche ausgangssperren das
sperren von einkaufsstraßen oder
kaufhäusern oder friseurin wäre ja
demnach keine effektive maßnahme zur
einschränkung des virus sondern eher
noch mehr maßnahmen im privaten bereich
in kneipen und bei feiern ist dass die
schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen kann
also die privaten umfeld sind die wo wir
am meisten infektionen zusammenstehen
das heißt da müssen wir wirklich sehr
viel energie darauf verwenden und es
gibt ja auch einige maßnahmen von den
bundesländern die in diese richtung
gehen also die beschränkung der anzahl
von menschen die sie im privaten umfeld
treffen die beschränkung von
veranstaltungen auf höchst zahlen von
teilnehmen und das geht ja alles genau
in diese richtung vielen dank
wir gehen zur n-tv harz ja gut ich
konnte aber kurz zurück auf seine
vorrednerin sie hat mir gesagt
infektionsgeschehen momentan vor allem
in der jugend wir dürfen uns aber nicht
die nicht in sicherheit wiegen weil die
feierlichkeiten noch nicht so hoch ist
denn sie wird wieder steigen bleibt
patrick gestern bei n tv gesagt deshalb
vielleicht doch zeit für einen umschwung
also virus weiter ernst nehmen aber
keine panik bekommen und man müsste den
fokus jetzt absolut selbst angesprochen
die gesundheitsämter kommen an ihre
grenzen den fokus absolut auf den schutz
von risiko wochen wegen und vielleicht
auch um die jugend einfach außen vor
lassen war das infektionsgeschehen dazu
vorhanden ist aber die
krankheitsverläufe eher milde sind also
ist es zeit für ein strategiewechsel
oder mindestens in den dreiklang gegen
sie genannt haben zwischen allen werbung
schilderung eine akzentverschiebung hin
zu massiven schutz der ressourcen also
wir haben diese strategie seit vielen
monaten gefahren und zwar seit anfang an
und unser land
ich denke das wird jeder der sich ein
wenig weiterbildung der die die zahlen
anschaut landkarten anschaut auch die
berichterstattung anschaut unser land
ist mit dieser strategie bislang
wirklich sehr sehr gut gefahren
das heißt es gibt gar kein anlass die
strategie zu wechseln
der schutz der wohlhabenden gruppen ist
immer ein wichtiger teil gewesen und er
wird auch immer ein wichtiger teil
bleiben und alle drei säulen müssen alle
nach bestem wissen und gewissen
weitergeführt werden von unserer seite
werden wir nicht dazu auffordern als
eine der säulen gegenüber anderen
weniger oder stärker bearbeitet wird
warum sage ich das so klar ich muss das
noch mal sehr deutlich machen
wir leben in einer demokratischen
offenen gesellschaft und da kann man
auch sehr stolz darauf sein dass man in
der er lebt und in unserer gesellschaft
ist es so dass die verschiedenen
altersgruppen eben auch in einem hohen
maße zusammenleben
das heißt also es kann ja gar nicht
gelingen dass man bestimmte
gruppierungen explizit von diesem
gesellschaftlichen leben konsequent über
viele monate ausblendet das geht nicht
und wir haben ja schließlich auch im
frühjahr denke ich genügend darüber
gesprochen genügend diskussion gehabt
wie das ist wenn die alten menschen
enkel ihre ihre großväter und großmütter
nicht mehr sehen und so weiter also das
heißt dieser gedanke der vielleicht rein
theoretisch begründet ist ist praktisch
weder umsetzbar noch vertretbar wir
werden alle drei pfeiler nach wie vor
nach bestem wissen und gewissen halten
und wenn sich die jungen in dem fall
momentan sind es die jungen wenn die
jungen weiter dafür sorge tragen oder
dafür mitverantwortung kann dass das
virus sich ausbreiten wird natürlich
auch die ansteckungsgefahr für die alten
und hochaltrigen steigen das ist doch
klar
das heißt also wir machen keinen
strategiewechsel sondern wir werden
alles dafür tun dass wir alle diese drei
pfeiler nach bestem wissen und gewissen
weiterfahren
kurz nach fall ja verstehe ich kurze
nachfrage den vorschlag von drosten eine
zusätzliche kennzahl die inzidenz der
über 50-jährigen über 60-jährigen
einzufrieren wenn das noch ermittlungen
infektionsgeschehen etwas besser
abzudecken
also ich würde wirklich alle bitten dass
sie immer gut unser situationsbericht
gelesen die tun wir jeden tag auf die
website und dort sind ja die ganzen
zahlen also wir haben da ja immer daten
drin also tabellen drin wo die
altersverteilung der positiven da steht
die die altersverteilung auch der
verstorbenen die informationen sind ja
da die der der gedanke von herrn drosten
ist nach meinem verständnis folgender
wir leben leider immer wieder dass es
leute gibt die sagen auch wir haben ja
noch so viele intensivbetten frei da ist
ja noch kapazität und bis das
ausgelastet ist ist es nicht so schlimm
das ist aus meiner sicht aus zwei
gründen zynisch das eine ist ich habe
und alle die wir hier im institut
arbeiten und ich bin
das auch die mehrheit der deutschen das
so sehen wir alle haben das ziel dass
möglichst wenig menschen natürlich
versterben an der krankheit und schwer
erkranken das ist das erste und das
zweite ist und das ist der gedanke
glaube ich auch von herrn drosten
wenn wir nur auf diese zahlen schauen
dann schauen wir vier wochen drei bis
vier wochen zurück wenn ich ihnen heute
sagen wir haben elf 1000 soundsoviel
infizierte dann haben die sich ja vor
ungefähr fünf sechs sieben tagen
infiziert wir gucken ja mit den
aktuellen meldezahlen immer nach hinten
und wenn wir in die betten gucken wo
dann die schwerkranken legen ihren
intensiv legen dann gucken wir drei vier
wochen nach hinten
wir sind also viel zu spät und das virus
ist ja ein biologisches agens das kann
man nicht einfach heute stoppen und dann
hat man morgen den effekt sondern wie
sie den effekt eher sind zwei drei
wochen
und darum ist eine kennzahl die die zum
beispiel in der über 50-jährigen weil
die ein höheres risiko schwer
zuckerkrank ist eine zahl die wir auch
durchaus besser herausarbeiten können
aber sie ist schon da und sie gibt den
aktuellen das aktuelle bild etwas besser
wider als die zahlen die im krankenhaus
liegenden schweren patienten die
teilweise auch beatmet werden vielen
dank wir bevor wir zur welt frau will
gehen noch ein kurzer organisatorischer
hinweis wer dran war bitte das händchen
dann senken damit auch ein bisschen den
überblick behalten
und falls jemand das händchen nicht
sieht das ist etwas versteckt bei webex
man muss eine eigene person quasi
anklicken und dann ist es ganz weit
unten sehr diskret aber es sollte sich
hoffentlich finden lassen so jetzt gehen
wir zur frau will
guten morgen ich hoffe sie können mich
heran jahr gehörte gut wunderbar wir
hören ja oder beziehungsweise wir
sprechen ja jetzt mit diesen über 11.000
neuinfektionen von einem rekordwert man
ja aber gleichzeitig auch immer dass
dieser wert schwer zu vergleichen ist
mit den werten aus der ersten welle weil
jetzt eben mehr getestet wird können sie
hier wieder vielleicht nochmal unter
einbezug auf der positivseite also
sozusagen der trefferquote bei den
selbst vielleicht doch versuchen dein
verhältnis herzustellen
ja auch da haben wir ja unsere daten ich
muss mal suchen wo die zahlen sind
soldaten in den situationsbericht es ist
so dass die zahlen der positiven also
dass er anders gesagt
immer wieder einlassungen das quasi wir
sehr viele positive haben die aber
eigentlich nur deshalb gesehen werden
will war halt mehr testen also es wurde
in wirklichkeit gar nicht mehr menschen
erkranken oder positiv sondern wie
testen nunmehr aber das ist nicht
korrekt wenn sie sich die zahlen
anschauen die wir auch haben das ist in
tabellen meines wissens im
situationsbericht nachgelesen wir hatten
ja teilweise zahlen da waren rund 9
prozent der testung und positiv glaube
ich zu den höchsten im märz im april und
inzwischen sieht das folgendermaßen aus
obwohl wir so viel testen und wir testen
ja teilweise in der woche mehr als eine
million tests führen wir durch dass er
sehr sehr viel steigt die anzahl der
positiven die ganze zeit kontinuierlich
an
wir hatten in der woche 31 also vor etwa
11 2 wochen da waren rund unter ein
prozent der getesteten personen positiv
wir testen seitdem aber immer relativ
gleich hohe zahlen pro woche
inzwischen sind wir bei etwa ja wir sind
über 3 prozent der positiven sind
inzwischen pose das heißt also obwohl
wir so viel testen steigt der anzahl der
positiven auch immer mit und was man da
vor allen dingen sie das ist ganz
interessant
es steigt in allen altersgruppen auch
also wir sehen zb bei den in der letzten
woche war das so das sind die die
zwischen 15 und 59 jährigen also die
jüngeren
ich bin noch 950 also deshalb zähle ich
mich noch zu den jüngeren
da haben wir inzwischen raten die an die
vier prozent positiv sind und bei den
kleinsten also den kindern 0 bis 4
beziehungsweise auch bei den
hochhaltigen über 80 da sind es auch
schon fast zweieinhalb prozent das heißt
also die raten steigen auch nicht nur
das ist also nicht nur bedingt durch die
erhöhte anzahl der testungen und in den
letzten wochen haben wir jede woche ein
die immer ziemlich gleich viel getestet
trotzdem steigen die raten
wir gehen zur forschung aktuell
wildermuth ja ich wollte noch mal auf
den aspekt zu kommen zurück kommen die
maßnahmen die politik sie haben gesagt
wir müssen alle individuell handelns
klar die politik macht jetzt eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen und droht im grunde
immer mit dem lockdown wenn nichts
passiert nach den infektionen zu ordnen
schalten lockt dann überhaupt nicht
sinnvoll zu sein weil er betrifft die
orte an denen wir uns eh nicht anstecken
also wo sind stellschrauben die politik
wirklich etwas bewirken kann
ja also das eine ist eine
einheitlichkeit also eine verbindliche
einheitlichkeit das halte ich für sehr
wichtig weil wir die menschen damit
natürlich mitnehmen und diese
verbindliche einheitlichkeit muss eben
mit bestimmten grenzen verbunden sein
das halte ich für sehr wichtig der
zweite aspekt ist da natürlich dass auch
eine verbindlichkeit ist das heißt also
auch eine entsprechende kontrolle ein
nachgehen dass diese dinge auch
eingehalten werden und der andere aspekt
den ich sehe ist der dass man eben
bestimmte obergrenzen für zusammenkünfte
wirklich definiert und die einheitliche
die sind desto besser ist es natürlich
es wir wissen also auch auf der aus der
cosmo studie das ist wirklich eine
hervorragende studie die übrigens auch
weltweit ziemlich einmalig ist es meines
wissens kein anderes land das so viele
daten punkte über die ganzen monate
immer repräsentativen der bevölkerung
erfasst wie diese kosmos studie
und wir wissen aus der studie dass die
mehrheit der menschen in deutschland
diese maßnahmen nachvollziehen kann und
trägt und das heißt also das ist nach
wie vor noch der der der wichtigste
aspekt weil wir ja diejenigen sind die
das virus weiter tragen und insofern
denke ich also diese verbindlichkeit
klare werte klare grenzwerte verbunden
mit einer möglich auch nach halten dass
die so gut wie möglich eingehalten
werden und dass gebunden an bestimmte
grenzwerte von seiten der der inzidenz
zahlen das ist die maßnahme die wir
fahren müssen und ich denke es ist
unheimlich wichtig dass die menschen
halt verstehen dass das sie wirklich
helfen sich schützen können also das ist
ja so wenn man sich an diese regeln hält
und dann wird im bekanntenkreis jemand
infiziert dann kann man sagen okay ich
hab den zwar getroffen aber ich habe
mich an die regeln gehalten und darum
ist man infektionsrisiko sehr sehr stark
verringert worden
und ich denke das bewusstsein ist da und
ich habe auch immer noch das gefühl es
gibt manchmal immer noch
missverständnisse was das genau heißt
diese aha regeln und ich glaube da
können wir noch mehr wahrscheinlich
aufklären und noch mehr tun dann können
wir das einfach in hohem maße schaffen
es gibt ja menschen im beruflichen
umfeld
die können bestimmten situationen nicht
entgehen ok trotzdem passen sie auf aber
im privaten umfeld kann man diesen
situationen entgehen und und diese
verantwortung die diese wachsamkeit die
müssen wir einfach alle mittragen
das war jetzt nicht ganz meine frage ich
wollte wissen welche stellschrauben sind
relevant also die politik sagt zum
beispiel masken auch in einkaufsstraßen
das wäre nach ihren ansteckungsrate
eigentlich nicht so relevant maske neben
öffentlichen nahverkehr wäre nicht so
relevant geschäftsschließungen als
lockdown wäre im grunde nicht so
relevant also will was sind wirklich die
stellschrauben wo sie sehen dass die
politik was bewirken kann also masken
pflicht in den räumen wo man sich
anstecken kann dazu gehört natürlich
auch der öffentliche personennahverkehr
die daten sprechen zwar dafür dass da
nicht viel passiert aber das heißt ja
nicht dass man das dann nicht trotzdem
etwas geschehen muss also verpflichtende
masken tragen
verpflichtendes masken tragen in
geschäften zum beispiel ist ein
wichtiger punkt an denen räumlichkeiten
in den innenräumen wo viele menschen
zusammenkommen
die anzahl der menschen die in
bestimmten räumen sein können die
lüftung man kann natürlich auch
stellschrauben setzen über zb
investitionsprogramme die in den letzten
monaten ja auch gefahren wurden dass man
bestimmte räume besser lüften kann wir
reden jetzt zum beispiel über schulen
also es gibt schon eine menge
stellschrauben die richtig sind und die
auch durchgeführt werden wir gehen zum
handelsblatt will man ja schon morgen
ich habe frage zu herdenimmunität es
wurde anfang der woche wieder intensiv
diskutiert können sie bitte noch mal
schildern was es bedeuten
wenn wir das virus nicht mehr eindämmen
können sie haben ja gesagt einzelne
gesundheitsämter sind schon nicht mehr
in der lage die alle fälle zu
kontrollieren und mit wie vielen
infizierten sagen sie mal eine
hochrechnung man rechnen müsste wenn man
es quasi laufen lässt weil man weil man
es nicht mehr in den griff bekommen dass
es gab vor ich glaube monaten zum
beispiel eine aussage von einem experten
dass wir bis weihnachten hunderttausend
tote haben könnten unter 65 jahren wenn
wir es laufen lassen ist das realistisch
oder ist als alarmismus
also es gibt verschiedene modellierungen
eine der modelle studien haben wir auch
selber publiziert im april ist ja immer
noch auf der website des robert koch
instituts also wenn man das virus laufen
lassen wird oder wenn wir anders
anfangen mit der herdenimmunität an also
dass das konzept ist ja in manchen
ländern teilweise ansatzweise versucht
worden und es ist ja gescheitert dass es
gibt niemanden mehr der sich ernsthaft
damit befasst der das prinzip der
herdenimmunität weiter verfolgt das
heißt also man lässt das laufen in der
hoffnung dass so viele menschen
infiziert werden und dann immunität
ausbilden weil wir einfach viele
krankheitsverläufe haben wie schwer
verlaufen da sind ja natürlich
hunderttausende von krankheitsverläufen
und millionen von infizierten wären das
dann das ist gar keine frage wenn man es
laufen ließ und darum macht das keinen
sinn
der zweite punkt ist der dass wir eben
in der bevölkerung im keine immunität
haben im gegensatz zur grippe wo wir bei
vielen menschen einen grund immunität
haben das heißt also die
krankheitsverläufe
während so schwer dass bei 80 millionen
deutschen wenn die alle infiziert wurden
auch wenn 70 prozent von denen infiziert
wurden dann werden ja 50 60 millionen
deutsche infiziert und wenn sie dann
dieselben zahlen zugrunde legen die wir
zurzeit haben dass wir bei 380.000
infizierten allein 400.000 dass wir dort
etwa 10.000 tote bislang haben dann kann
man sich das ja ausrechnen was das
heissen würde also die die zahlen der
infizierten toten werden sehr sehr hoch
das ist
keine frage können sie nochmal
nachfragen sind folgende sagt einzelnen
staaten haben es schon aufgegeben
welche sind das vor allem also es gab
starten die haben im frühjahr die
kontakt nachverfolgen ausgegeben dazu
gehörte zum beispiel schweden
dazu gehörte zum beispiel großbritannien
das heißt das sind länder die dann so
überwältigt worden dass sie das wirklich
eingestellt haben und dass das hat sich
als nicht der richtige weg erwiesen
wir gehen zulässt seco ich hoffe spreche
ist richtig aus frau renault ja guten
tag hören sie mich ja ich wollte wissen
ob deutschland oder das vermag ich ihnen
nicht zu sagen ich glaube dass wir das
könnten
ich kann aber nicht ich weiß nicht ob
das geschieht aktuell ich weiß dass zum
beispiel momentan aus den niederlanden
auch patienten in deutschland behandelt
werden ich weiß dass es aus einigen
ländern anfragen gibt aber ich kann ihn
nicht genau sagen aus welchen ländern
das tatsächlich stattfindet zurzeit gibt
es zurzeit gibt es noch kapazitäten ja
das ist korrekt
na ja wir haben in deutschland rund
30.000 intensivbetten wir haben dieses
die wie register die dass die zahlen
dieses deutschen intensiv medizin und
internisten register die sind ja auch
auf unserer website und in unserem tages
bricht immer vorhanden
jetzt habe ich die zahl aber nicht ganz
im kopf muss ich sagen vielleicht die
vor glasmacher aber sind also noch
einige tausend betten theoretisch frei
sind im moment belegt etwa 980.000 sind
etwa belegt zurzeit mit patienten mit
kuwait patienten aber es gibt natürlich
auch betten belegt sind mit anderen
patienten also man kann die zahl dieser
30.000 nicht nur auf die core i
patienten beziehen
wir gehen zufolge können sie noch sagen
welches medium sie vertreten den
westdeutschen rundfunk und
wirtschaftlich redaktion professor busse
von der tu berlin hat am montag in dem
briefing vom smc gesagt dass man die
entwicklungen von deutschland dass sie
ungefähr fünf wochen hinter denen von
niederlande und belgien liegt meine
frage ist ist kann man sagen dass wir
einfach den anderen ländern einige
wochen hinterher hinken oder gibt es
auch anzeichen dafür vielleicht dass es
bei uns weniger heftig verlaufen wird
also es gibt zum einen die anzeichen die
dafür sprechen dass wir es aufhalten
können das heißt nicht dass wir das auch
schaffen aber nur wir können es schaffen
wenn wir uns an diese regeln halten sind
die das war ja über den ganzen sommer
und die ganzen monate auch schon
deutlich bessere verläufe haben wir
können das natürlich schaffen aber wie
gesagt wir schaffen es echt nur wenn wir
uns gemeinsam anstrengen es gibt aber
noch einen anderen aspekt der natürlich
auch zu beachten ist wir haben insgesamt
gerade im intensivmedizinischen bereich
schon mehr kapazitäten also wir können
schon noch mehr personen behandeln wenn
es denn sein müsste
und wir müssen auch sagen dass wir im
bereich des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes auch wenn der in den
letzten jahrzehnten stiefmütterlich
behandelt wurde und nicht genügend
ausgestattet wurde so wie wir uns das in
unserem bereich des public als wünschen
so ist er immer noch doch stark im
vergleich zu manch anderen ländern das
heißt also es muss nicht so sein dass
wir in fünf wochen da stehen wo jetzt
die nachbarstaaten stehen aber es kann
sein und damit das eben nicht geschieht
müssen wir alle uns wirklich anstrengen
und dann können wir schaffen dass wir
das doch verhindern
vielen dank wir gehen zu herrn rinke
können sie auch noch sagen welche
redaktionen sie vertreten
hallo andreas rinke von reuters
wieder ich habe eine frage zur cola
waren sie bisher nicht erwähnt es gibt
ja forderungen dass man die nach
technisch sind sie dafür
sehen sie eine chance dass das passiert
und eine ganz kurze nach halle zu etwas
was sie vorher gesagt haben nämlich die
zedenten es gibt ja auch den vorschlag
dass man einen neuen wert bei 100 100
halten sie das für sie also die korona
waren app wird er kontinuierlich
weiterentwickelt wir haben inzwischen so
an die 20 millionen downloads
sie wissen dass wir auf gründen des
datenschutzes bestimmte informationen
nicht haben aber sie wird weiter
entwickelt und das halte ich auch für
sinnvoll es ist inzwischen eine
diskussion im gange
wir werden sehen was diese diskussion
noch alles ergeben aber wir wissen auf
jeden fall dass die krone waren es einen
wert hat sie bringt einen mehrwert und
die mehr menschen die nutzen desto
besser ist es
wir werden sehen welche entwicklungen in
den nächsten wochen und monaten noch
möglich sind das ist kann ich wirklich
nicht prophezeien
aber sie können sicher sein dass wir da
kontinuierlich drüber nachdenken
und wir haben halt auch immer den
datenschutz zu beachten und sind ja
immer ein sehr intensiver austausch
unter anderem mit dem bundesdatenschutz
verantwortlichen also über
weiterentwicklung wird nachgedacht jetzt
ist ja zunächst mal in anderen ländern
auch nutzbar divina länder werden noch
ausgeweitet diese interoperabilität wird
stärker vorangetrieben und wir haben es
auch die möglichkeit symptome einzugeben
das ist auch eine weiterentwicklung weil
die app warnt ja aufgrund eines
algorithmus an allen komplizierter
algorithmus der eine bestimmte
wahrscheinlichkeit einer infektion zu
übertragen mit einberechnet und die mehr
symptome wir von den menschen bekommen
die positiv getestet wurden desto
genauer können wir den algorithmus
einstellen als auch das ist eine
weiterentwicklung sicher und die die
zweite frage aber jetzt hat sich wieder
vergessen die nachfrage ach ja der
grenzwert also ich halte nichts von von
anpassung von grenzwerten
wir haben man kann ja nicht
also wenn man wenn sie irgendwo
hochwasser haben dann tun sie dann nicht
auch plötzlich die hochwassermarke höher
ihre dämme haben nur eine gewisse höhe
wir sollten uns schon an diesen an
diesen werten weiter dran halten will
die unsere maßnahmen wirklich stark
beeinflussen und wenn es dann drüber
geht müssen wir eben versuchen stärker
dagegen zu arbeiten aber so dass man
grenzfälle anpasst vermindert man ja
nicht die problematik
wir gehen zu herrn schmidt johann sind
und wenn sie auch noch ihre redaktion
bitte dazu sagen
die gestern von der aktion zu dem
leidigen lebenssituation berichtet
deswegen haben wir uns alle objekte
andere daten die aus buchs
berichterstattung jetzt detailliert
aufgenommen wird da hat mir auch schon
ganz oft danach gefragt wir würden uns
natürlich freuen wenn die alle daten die
in diesem bericht sind auch zur
verfügung stellen das nicht mögen hier
ist lesen können sondern auch über
automatisierten knöpfe das würde der
berichterstattung helfen damit wir ihre
details die sie jetzt liefern auch eben
aufbereiten das hat eine inhaltliche
frage das stück von cluster ist es nicht
logisch und nachvollziehbar dass hier
und warte ausbrüchen jetzt besser
durchleuchten weil wir eben auch
kontaktpersonen ersten grades testen und
damit in der familie im umfeld im
unmittelbaren umfeld neben viele weitere
angesteckten personen identifizieren
können aber damit sagt ist doch gar
nichts aus wo der ursprüngliche
infektionsherd war und es hat mich damit
eigentlich ein ja irreführende aussagen
ist vor allem ansteckungen im privaten
umfeld gab die gab es auch schon in der
ersten welt gesehen und ist nicht die
frage wie wollen wir eigentlich die
quell cluster mit den mitteln der
kontakt nach verfolgung besser
identifizieren
ja also
es gelingt natürlich nicht immer das
quell cluster zu finden dass das ist ja
klar aber sind zwei stränge glaube ich
die man im kopf haben muss das eine ist
man schaut nach hinten und man versucht
das quält cluster zu finden und wenn es
gelingt ist es gut und wenn es nicht
gelingt ist es eben weniger gut auch mal
wird trotzdem immer noch bestimmte
kontaktpersonen ja in quarantäne stecken
können und damit verhindern dass ist
dass sie möglicherweise etwas übertragen
der andere punkt ist aber dass nach
vorne schauen das dürfen sie auch nicht
vergessen wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
ist so genannte super spreading events
gibt also events wo eine person oder
wenige personen sehr sehr viele andere
anstecken
dann ist natürlich auch klar dass das
war dadurch dass wir diejenigen die
vielleicht anstecken sind in quarantäne
tun
die können ja dann auch nicht mehr
ausgangspunkt für neues quell cluster
sein und können dann eben auch nicht
mehr
größere veranstaltungen besuchen falls
sie überhaupt noch zugelassen sind also
das heißt sie haben insofern recht als
das ist uns natürlich nicht immer
gelingen wird quält laster
nachzuvollziehen aber der entscheidende
aspekt ist glaube ich der zum einen dass
wir wirklich aufpassen dass wir eben gar
nicht solche situationen schaffen wo
überhaupt ein quell cluster entstehen
kann und das andere ist ein punkt wo wir
einfach darauf angewiesen sind dass die
leute sich erinnern wo sie gewesen waren
und dafür ist zum beispiel das auch von
herrn thorsten vorgeschlagenen kontakt
nach buch also in ein tagebuch wo man
wann gewesen ist ist natürlich da eine
große hilfe aber ich kann nur sagen die
die die suche und der der
gesundheitsämter geht ja immer nach
hinten hat sie versuchen
nachzuvollziehen wo eine person gewesen
ist das gelingt mal besser mal
schlechter aber jede person die sie dann
in dem rahmen identifizieren ist eine
die nach vorne hin kein neues quell
cluster auf jeden fall hervorrufen kann
und das ist auch schon ein sehr hoher
wert vielen dank
eine frage ist schriftlich gekommen das
machen wir normalerweise nicht da war
ausnahmsweise jetzt mal schauen die
pharmazeutische zeitung frau komani die
frage wann hat sie an impfstart in
deutschland für realistisch wie lange
wird es dauern bis alle
oft sind gestern hat die eu-kommission
etwas von einem stadion sechs monaten
verlauten lassen die wir oft sprach
anfang der woche von mitte 221 sonst war
immer von jahreswechsel die reben die
usa die rede
die usa sprachen dagegen heute nach
davon dass bis april alle amerikaner
geimpft sein könnten
ja also das ist eine frage die immer
wieder kommt die wir alle wirklich nicht
richtig beantworten können nicht ich
sage ihnen warum wir die nicht richtig
beantworten können also wir gehen alle
davon aus dass im nächsten jahr
impfstoffe in deutschland zugelassen
werden und das dann eben im nächsten
jahr auch geimpft wird wann das genau
sein wird das können wir nicht wissen
und ich sage in den grund warum wir das
nicht wissen können es gibt eine reihe
von sehr vielversprechenden klinischen
studien wenn man einen impfstoff zulässt
dann gibt es drei phasen drei studien
und diese studien fangen an mit einer wo
man schaut ob der impfstoff
nebenwirkungen hat ob er also quasi
schädlich ist mit sehr kleinen patienten
oder probandengruppen und bisschen in
der dritte phase dritte klinische phase
dort werden mehrere zehntausend menschen
geimpft und dann beobachtet man die eine
gewisse zeit um zu sehen ob die impfung
wirkt aber auch ob es nebenwirkungen
gibt
und das heißt also wenn alles optimal
läuft dann laufen diese studien gut
durch wie geplant in den bestimmten
zeitraum dann werden sie ausgewertet und
wenn dann eben herauskommt dass sie
wirken und keine nebenwirkungen haben
dann erfolgte die zulassung aber wenn in
diesen klinischen studien nebenwirkungen
auftreten das haben sie ja auch schon
wir haben das mehrfach schon gesehen ich
glaube zwei klinischen studien gab es
neben wirkende gab es zumindest
ereignisse dann wurde überprüft ob die
auf die impfung zurückzuführen waren
oder eben einfach nur ereignisse die die
zeitlich parallel mit zusammenhang mit
der impfung dann hat man die teilweise
angehalten die klinischen studien und
sie dann erst weiter fortgeführt man
weiß ja nicht wie sie ausgehen aber ich
bin sehr optimistisch dass einige dieser
studien positiv laufen werden und dann
wird es im nächsten jahr zugelassene
impfstoffe geben und dann ist ja die
frage welcher der impfstoffe wird es
denn sein manche impfstoff hersteller
produzieren es bereits impfstoffe quasi
im vorgriff in der hoffnung in dem mit
dem optimismus dass sie dann auch später
angewendet werden und da kommt es darauf
an wie viele dosen das sind die dann
wirklich zugelassen
das sind so viele aber dass es eben
nicht genau zu sagen ist und wenn die
impfstoffe da sind dann nochmal da gibt
es bestimmte menge von impfstoffen die
dann zum beispiel für deutschland zur
verfügung stehen und dann muss man
natürlich genau schauen wen man zuerst
und da sind ja gerade intensive
planungen von der ständigen
impfkommission welche gruppen werden
wohl zuerst geimpft und das werden
natürlich zum einen diejenigen sein die
ein hohes risiko haben angesteckt zu
werden und es sind zum anderen
diejenigen die ein besonders hohes
risiko haben dass sie schwer erkranken
und dann je nachdem wie viel impfstoff
wo ist wird das dann logistisch so
verteilt dass die menschen so schnell
wie möglich geimpft werden aber da sind
so viele wenn und abers dass ich ihnen
diese zeit punkte sicher nicht nennen
kann
wir gehen zu herrn reisen sagen sie auch
noch bitterer redaktion dazu jugend a
country die aktuell tagesschau de
eine nachfrage ist der schule und zwar
ist es ja so dass es vom rkw
empfehlungen gibt die auch da ein
bestimmten incident von 35 50 verfahren
ist und dass die bundesländer diese
empfehlung aber durch die bank
eigentlich nicht umsetzen
zum beispiel teilen wir die klassen
nicht einmal so zu sagen ihre meinung
dazu
sie schätzen wir dass einen die
beobachten das ja also die empfehlungen
die wir machen sind eben empfehlungen
wir machen sie nach bestem wissen und
gewissen wir haben sie ja schon mehrfach
angepasst um sie auch lebbar zu machen
und ich bedaure das natürlich das ist ja
gar keine frage
natürlich machen wir die empfehlung in
der hoffnung dass sie eben dann auch
umgesetzt werden aber ich weiß auch dass
es schulen gibt die diese empfehlung
umsetzen
aber ich habe keinen überblick darüber
wie viel prozent der schulen sind das
hängt auch steil weise einfach stark ab
von den schulleitern von dem
zusammenspiel zwischen schulleitungen
und gesundheitsämter ich weiß dass es
schulen gibt die diese empfehlungen
einhalten
ich kann ihnen aber nicht sagen wie viel
es sind ich weiß nur eins wir haben ja
schon mehrere hundert ausbrüche in
schulen gesehen
wir wissen dass es ausbrüche in schulen
gibt wir wissen dass die schulen
nicht im gegensatz zur influenza da sind
die schulen wirklich ein richtiger
treiber von den influenza wählen oder
oder auch wenn es eine pandemie gäbe
dann sind die schulkinder wirklich
treiber von dieser pandemie
das ist bei der kogit 19 erkrankung
nicht der fall
aber es ist natürlich klar je mehr
menschen sich in deutschland infizieren
desto größer ist natürlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass infektionen auch
in schulen auftreten
und deshalb sind die empfehlungen aus
unserer sicht sehr sehr wichtig
einzuhalten vielen dank wir haben jetzt
noch drei fragen und die bitte ich
jeweils kurz zu stellen und auch mit dem
blick auf die uhr geguckt zu warten
frau christa alle guten morgen
was halten sie von der idee das ist ganz
abhängig von der lokalen situation
das robert-koch-institut empfiehlt
sollte schott bei uns ja nicht aber das
ist lokal abhängig von der situation ist
müssen die gesundheitsämter entscheiden
ob das in der jeweiligen
epidemiologischen situation sinn macht
ich habe nochmal frage zu
zusammenkünften von vielen menschen zum
einen aber nachfrage bei schulen auch
wenn ich es richtig verstanden hat ist
es ja eigentlich eher weniger antreiber
wie sie sagten und grinst
infektionsgeschehen war betrachtete die
flächen deckte flächendeckende
schulschließung vor paar monaten
trotzdem der richtige weg und eigentlich
ähnliches thema konzertsäle zum beispiel
also großveranstaltungen gibt es ja
welche die zum beispiel eine ffp zwei
maske verpflichtend machen für besucher
und damit heute schon 70 prozent ihrer
kapazität wieder fahren können
hätten sie es mit einer app p2 maske
vielleicht auch für möglich dass größere
kapazitäten in richtung 100 prozent
wieder möglich sind also wenn alle
besucher so eine maske verpflichtung
trage von hohem standard danke also
unsere empfehlungen sind ja ziemlich
klar
wir sagen wir wir wünschen dass die
menschen einen bestimmten abstand halten
hygieneregeln einhalten und da womöglich
eben alltags masken tragen
das sind konzepte die wir so nicht
empfehlen wenn das vor ort dann
teilweise gemacht wird dann ist das eben
die entscheidung der lokalen behörden
vor ort die das zulassen und das
entsprechend auch überprüfen müssen und
nach prüfen müssen welche effekte das
hat zu ihrer ersten frage den
schulschließungen der also damals gab es
wirklich eine sehr große unsicherheit
und es gab damals zu schulen ja
überhaupt keine daten das muss man
einfach sagen das heißt wir hat eine
große unsicherheit und ich halte das
deshalb in dieser phase für richtig aber
ich möchte auch noch mal generell etwas
sagen das eine ist eher der
infektionsschutz
das ist ja das was unser business ist wo
wir eine hohe expertise haben und wo wir
eben nach bio medizinisch
wissenschaftlichen kenntnissen der
bestmöglichen wissen und kenntnissen
diese empfehlungen herausgeben das
andere ist natürlich eine balance die
die gesellschaft finden muss und das ist
eben das was die politischen
entscheidungsträger dann vor ort zu
entscheiden haben diese balance hat sich
deutschland dafür entschieden das eben
schulen wirklich von hoher wichtigkeit
den aus vielen gründen da sind
ökonomische gründe das sind gründe der
bildung dass das sind gründe der
teilhabe und hier muss in der
gesellschaft natürlich abfliegen was
ihnen wichtiger ist oder nicht und ich
denke das ist eine entscheidung die das
robert-koch-institut eben nicht trifft
wird treffen empfehlungen auf bestem
wissen und gewissen wie wir dafür sorge
tragen dass ein virus nicht von einem
menschen zum anderen kommt das ist unser
business wie das umgesetzt wird ist dann
eine aufgabe der leute vor ort
wir kommen zur letzten frage metropol fm
wer hat ford europa jetzt richtig guten
tag
die mit ja wir haben sie von tag 1
führung und tag herr professor doktor
wiener größte sieg us mein name
metropole nachrichtenredaktionen nach
ihrer einschätzung der lage und dem
weiter dynamisch wachsenden
infektionsverlauf stellt sich die frage
welche weiteren möglichen maßnahmen
erwägen sie vor einem eventuellen zwei
punkte und wäre nach momentaner
infektions leider nicht eine
einheitliche unsere zweite mast nicht
von vorteil
na ja ich hatte ja gesagt dass wir oder
ich habe noch nicht alle ausgeführt wir
haben eine reihe von werkzeugen die die
die sind glaube ich allen
entscheidungsträgern bekannt und diese
werkzeuge müssen eben alle konsequent
eingesetzt werden und dazu gehört
natürlich auch ein bundeseinheitliches
vorgehen vorgehen gerichtet an
bestimmten kennzahlen und ich denke da
ist immer noch wie man so schön sagt
luft nach oben das auch wirklich
durchzuführen wir haben den
werkzeugkasten und damit können wir das
schaffen
aber der muss eben auch konsequent
angewendet werden das ist das einzige
was ich dazu sagen kann
denn mehr als diesen werkzeugkasten
haben wir eben auch nicht und wir müssen
den dann so lange optimal ausnutzen bis
wir dann im nächsten jahr eben
irgendwann impfstoffe haben diese
impfstoffe die das ist schon game
changer damit können wir dann natürlich
auf dauer diese pandemie auch
kontrollieren und wir haben in den
werkzeugkasten ja noch jetzt ein
werkzeug mehr unter anderem die anti gen
tests die auch noch ein ein tool sind
dafür einsetzen können mit dem wieder
mehr informationen bekommen mit denen
wir wieder schneller reagieren können
wenn es darum geht infizierte patienten
eben aus dem verkehr zu ziehen und zu
isolieren
also der werkzeugkasten ist
kontinuierlich gewachsen und deshalb
haben wir eigentlich immer mehr die
chance es zu machen wir müssen sie eben
nur wirklich konsequent an nutzen höher
an ein also ihre empfehlung wäre in
diesem falle die maske im öffentlichen
bereich konsequent zu tragen also in dem
bereich wo menschen zusammenkommen
insbesondere in innenräumen ganz klar ja
ich will eine regelung dass die
empfehlungen vielen dank das war ein
schönes schlusswort bleiben sie gesund
und bis zum nächsten mal daran wieder
schauen